rick new heisel former ucla head coach
and now working for cbs cbs college
football analyst and uh also coached at
washington and colorado he knows the
pac-12 in in other words and uh rick
kind enough to join us explain the
timing of usc's decision to fire clay
helton
makes no sense i mean clay had uh been
hanging on in what i call coaching
purgatory for
seems like the last three or four years
i mean he was hanging on like that cat
was hanging on in
in miami
i mean uh
but to do it in week two
is a little bit questionable because now
it puts if you really think dante
williams is a good coach
you put him in in kind of harm's way
because if he does well the players just
like they did for mario cristobal and
oregon are going to be clamoring he
should be the guy
and is he really going to be the guy
that you're going to go forward with
that to me is a precarious situation and
if he doesn't do well you've lost one of
your best recruiters
what is the upside to this
the upside to this is look you're
telling your constituency the trojan
faithful that you're going back to
trying to be a dynasty you realize you
were kind of a fringe player all along
during this
last regime and
that isn't good enough
yeah i just wondered if it
was the on that short of a leash that it
was and i know losing to stanford and
losing at home being embarrassed and
ucla is starting to rise a little bit
like i don't know if the two are
connected at all am i connecting the
dots and they shouldn't be connected i
don't think that has much to do with it
i think it does have something to do
with it that they're getting ready for a
new television deal and they want to
signal to the television partners
that uh hey we're sc is going to be
a different animal going back to the
days of glory quote unquote listen when
clay helton went small ball when he
hired uh cliff kingsbury and then cliff
off to the uh off to the nfl so he had
to stay within the same genre otherwise
it looked like he was just hiring a name
he goes with graham harrell
you lose a lot of history with usc i
mean this is a place for ron yerry
anthony munoz
keith van horn brad buddy don mosebar
tony bacelli i mean elijah vera tucker
was a first rounder but they averaged
dan less than 100 yards a game rushing
three yards a carry last year this this
they used to be the bullies on the block
going down the tunnel at the coliseum
with those guys in there you're like oh
my goodness
they went small ball and it was uh it's
not what you do when you're a dominant
program
well give me the state of this program
let's you know usc needs to be honest
with usc
right they they need to go back to
financing
their expectations they need to go and
that's what mike bone said in this
dismissal letter that he has given them
added resources
they need now to go back and use the
power that they wield in the world of
recruiting i wouldn't even be shocked if
they went and got an nfl gm given all
the different ways to uh amass talent
now via the transfer portal via go get a
bunch of nil deals uh in in los angeles
that are going to be readily available
for kids that are going to be coming to
the program
and and
go back to being the dominant team
the name that i'm going to throw out
there
and i don't know if urban's gonna like
the nfl but urban meyer is the guy that
i would be circling but i thought that
they
he was tops on the list but then it was
vetoed by the higher ups that yeah but
yeah but the higher-ups now have also
now
seen what happens when they don't have
the guy that they need and urban's been
hired already so if somebody else has
hired him it now makes it easier for you
to uh you can see that he's made amends
blah blah blah
could you see urban meyer one and done
in the nfl rick yes
why urban meyer is a control guy
and i don't say that disparagingly he
wants total control the nfl athlete is a
different animal
and
sometimes his way of doing things will
fall on some deaf ears which will drive
him crazy
could you call urban meyer now
for january
you can make overtures yeah you can you
can uh go back channels and and you know
try to get to his people and see if
there's any interest now obviously it's
only one game in and if jacksonville has
a complete you know uh change of uh
course and becomes uh you know close to
a playoff team or a playoff team then
then this would all go out the window
but if this has the kind of season that
i don't think is a far-fetched idea
meaning that it's a three four five win
team
urban meyer might say you know what i'm
more of a college guy okay i'm gonna
throw out a name
while we're throwing out names yes
because
urban meyer can't be won and done in the
nfl
lane kiffin
keyshawn likes lane kiffin i think
too big a leap for the uh trojan
administration to go back there i mean
if you're gonna do that why wouldn't you
go back to sarc
right now lane kiffin has this kind of
aura about him that somehow mysteriously
he can build it but lane kiffin does it
in the same way he small balls it he's
throwing it all over the place now they
run the ball more than uh sc does but i
still think you need somebody
like i i tell you bill o'brien bill
o'brien might be in on this deal mm-hmm
uh if he has his kind of year i don't
think you can sell that luke fickle yeah
i think that's the guy yeah luke fickle
but the question is can he recruit the
west coast urban
trust me urban's where they're where
they're going to try to butter their
bread well we might as well go all the
way to the top and go pete carroll bring
pete carroll back
while we're at it rick
yeah while we're at it i mean
listen and pete could probably do it but
pete seems pretty happy there in seattle
yeah but i'm trying to understand you
know they they don't keep talent in
southern california they're letting all
these great quarterbacks leave southern
california you may not you may not get
them out of high school right away but
you can get them on the bounce back
that's what sonny dykes has done at smu
he's got a bunch of dallas kids coming
back to uh
smu and and their team is i mean last
year they were the first time ranked
since 1984. the transfer portal has
given you two bites at the apple now for
these kids that are from local and like
i said i wouldn't be surprised if you go
and get the the new model i think is
go get a general manager that's going to
help you
look at all these different uh arenas to
find talent and amass yourselves with
them one thing usc has always been
willing to do is let you get players
into school
so
wait are you still bitter how does that
sound
did i come off a little bit bitter maybe
it was the 50 to nothing thrashing i
took dan as a matter of fact you were
there yes i was you were there yes i was
not for the whole game
no that mercifully yeah and i was on the
other sideline well um assess what we've
seen so far ucla roughs up lsu at home
and oregon goes on the road to beat ohio
state
is this an anomaly or is uh pac-12 for
real
those two teams are not anomalies
they're both physically built uh chip
kelly i've said many times should have
been a service academy coach because of
his affinity for running the football
schematically he's ahead of most
in the run game and now he's got two
bruising backs that kid from michigan
charbonnet and the kid from duke brown
both transfers again showing you that
you can find ways to get players uh
they're the real deal and if the
quarterback can have any kind of year
they're going to be in this race all the
way to the end
the oregon win was fantastic
beautifully done it
may be more about ohio state's defense
than it is about oregon's uh
team i think we're gonna have to wait
and see uh where they are defensively
they gave up 600 yards of offense and
still found a way to win because they
were able to control it
i'm not sure there aren't some better
defenses right now that they'll see
later in the season
in particular ucla who looked really
good against lsu the worry in the pac-12
is the bottom half they're the only
power five team with three oh and two
teams and in particular washington
because washington's vital to the uh
pac-12 success as well
always great to talk to you make us
smarter thank you bud
see you dan
that's rick newheisel coached at
washington colorado ucla